[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार सब
लोग बता दीजिए की सबको मेरी आवाज ए रही है
नहीं ए रही
फिर चाट में कंफर्म कर दीजिए
ओके थैंक यू तो आप सभी का स्वागत करने के
युटुब चैनल पर तो अभी तक हमने फास्ट
क्लासेस में कितना जब भी कुछ पड़ा है अब
ये कम करते हैं हम उसके बड़े में अब क्या
करते प्रैक्टिकल देखते हैं कुछ लैब है
उनके थ्रू हम देखते हैं की आप लोगों को आप
लोग बार-बार बोल रहे थे ना की ज्यादा हमें
कुछ प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिस करने हैं कुछ
मिल नहीं रहा टास्क दीजिए
बस हम जस्ट वीडियो फॉलो कर रहे हैं नोट्स
बना रहे हैं बस हमें क्या की कुछ भी देखने
को नहीं मिल रहा की हमें क्या करना है
कैसे परफॉर्म करना है चलो फिर हम लाइव
सॉल्व करते हैं और काफी जिले में
डिफिकल्टी लेवल का इजी है और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग लाइव इसमें मैक्सिंग
टेक्निक्स आपकी उसे हो जाएगी और सेंड है
और जो आपका बाकी जो पैटर्न बच्चा है वो
आपका जो इसमें गेम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं
इंस्टाग्राम और सेंड और बाकी कुछ और थोड़ी
बहुत ही चीज बच्ची हुई है उनको भी हम क्या
करेंगे
लेकिन अब क्या है
है आप लोगों को यह डेमो दिखाने की चीज
कैसे कम में आई एक लैब के करो
तो एक कम करते हैं
तो चलो फिर हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
तो इस क्षेत्र बिल इंक्लूड सम ग्रेट
टेक्स्ट तू हेल्प गाइड यू इन डी राइट
डायरेक्शन एस वेल एस वन और मोर क्वेश्चंस
डेट नीड तू बी आंसर इन ऑर्डर तू कंटिन्यू
ऑन विद डी इन्वेस्टिगेशन बेसिकली इसमें
क्या है की आपको हर के क्वेश्चंस का आंसर
देने से पहले एक चैलेंज है और चैलेंज को
पूरा करने के लिए आपको क्या है बस एक
थोड़ा सा हिंट दिया हुआ है की जिसके थ्रू
आप क्या कर सुकून की अपने जो चैलेंज है
उसको कंप्लीट कर पाव टास्को कंप्लीट कर
पाव यहां पे बेगिनेर है और बिगनर को बहुत
साड़ी चीज क्या है स्टार्टिंग में चैलेंज
होती है इसलिए क्या है की आपको जस्ट एक
हिंट के तोर पर कुछ चीजों को डिस्क्राइब
किया है उनके बड़े में आपको पता होना
चाहिए
आप रेडी हो तो लेट को इसमें लिख दीजिए ओके
हम लेट
एस को
क्लियर ए रही है
प्लीज जल्दी से चाट में बता दीजिए
ओके
ओके कम कर देखो
स्टार्ट करते हैं
आइटम्स था तेरे इस नो मेजर डैमेज और देवर
दस नोट अपर तू बी अन्य अदर सिग्निफिकेंट
इंडिकेटर ऑफ कंप्रोमाइज ऑन अन्य ऑफ ओवर
सिस्टम हॉवेवर ड्यूरिंग फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस
अवर एडमिंस फाउंड और इमेज लेफ्ट बिहाइंड
डी साइबर की बेसिकली क्या है की ये एक
लेफ्ट डिजाइन की है जिसमें ये बोला है की
वो एक साइबर अटैक हुआ है जिसमें कुछ
ज्यादा खास डैमेज हुआ नहीं है बट क्या है
की कुछ इंडिकेशन इंडिकेटर है क्योंकि जब
फॉरेंसिक एनालिसिस थे जो उनके एडमिन थे
उन्होंने क्या किया जब एनालिसिस किया था
वहां पर कुछ प्रेजेंस मिले अटैक करके
साइबर अटैक करके तो वहां पर आपको क्या है
की इमेज है इमेज मिली है वहां पर जो धोखे
से या जानबूझकर छोड़ दी गई है साइबर
क्रिमिनल के द्वारा
देखने को मिल रहे हैं की
अटैक पहुंचने के लिए
आपको क्या है थोड़े से कुछ लो मिल रहे हैं
तो
तो तभी कॉपिड दाल इमेज लेफ्ट
ओपन कर लिया है और आप पढ़ने हैं
इंस्ट्रक्शंस में क्या लेकर देगा इमेज
स्कैन
ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन बहुत अंदर सर्फेस आगे वेल
आगे और बिल्ड विदीन डी फाइव एयर सेल्फ
ह्यूमन फंड इनफॉरमेशन सर्च व्हेन ए फोटोस
यू बिल नीड तू
इमेज फाउंड बाय डी ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंस
दो जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर इन ऑर्डर तू ऑब्टेन
बेसिक इनफॉरमेशन ऑन डेट देखो अब हमारे पास
एक इमेज है अब इमेज
ये है इमेज के बड़े में क्या कर सकते हैं
इसको इंस्पेक्टर
कम करता हूं साइड बाय साइड बाय ओपन कर
देता हूं उसको
[संगीत]
इमेज
कंट्रोल प्लस प्लस
के ऊपर जो आप इमेज देखोगे जो आपको दिखाई
दे रही होगी इसके ऊपर अगर ध्यान से देखोगे
जूम करके इसको भी कट कर देता हूं बैंड कर
देता हूं इसके ऊपर वैसे देखो देखो अगर मैं
इसको जूम करता हूं कुछ
[संगीत]
रोड पीएनजी करते हैं इसको अगर मैं और पंजी
करता हूं उसके बाद से करता हूं तो अगर मैं
इसको ओपन करता हूं फिर एक बार टर्मिनल के
अंदर डाउनलोड के अंदर
ओके
डाउनलोड
ओके ओके ओके
डाउनलोड में
क्या करते हैं
[संगीत]
सबसे पहले
एग्जिट पाल उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं इसे
डाउनलोड
इसके बाद इसके परमीशंस हमें का मतलब नहीं
है वो देखो यहां पर इमेज विथ इमेज हाइट
कुछ खास नहीं अभी देखो हमें कुछ यहां पे
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही है अगर आप
लोगों को ध्यान में जा रहा है तो क्योंकि
देखो अब क्या है इमेज और दिस इसे कर रहे
थे इमेज
तो आपको ये कुछ देखने को मिल रहा होगा
देखो हालांकि नाम तो हमने पीएनजी रखा था
लास्ट में लेकिन यहां पर कुछ आपको पाठ
देखने को मिल रहा है
एक्सपोर्ट हुई है उसका आपको देखने को क्या
मिलता है एक पाठ देखने को मिल रहा है अब
ये पास हो सकता है देखो की जहां से
एक्सपोर्ट किया की जो राशि स्कोर सिस्टम
पर भेजो गया है तो ये हो सकता है की वो जब
इसने क्या की इसका जो मटर है क्लियर करना
भूल गया क्या है क्लियर करना भूल गया या
जानबूझकर हमारे लिए ट्रेस छोड़ें हो तो
अपने आप को प्रूफ करने के लिए बोल गया तो
इसका मतलब क्या है उसमें आपने होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर अब ये देखो ये क्या हो
सकता है जैसे हम डायरेक्टली अंदर जैसे
डेस्कटॉप पी / ए तो यहां पर आप देख रहे हो
मतलब ये यूजर नाम हो सकता है ये क्या हो
सकता है एक कोई भी यूजर नाम हो सकता है
उसको मैं कम करता हूं कॉपी करता हूं अगर
और इसमें गूगल करता हूं मैं और ये ओपन
युटुब कर देता हूं पेस्ट और को कर देता
हूं उसके बाद में क्या करता हूं आपको इधर
देख अगर राइट के लिए करता हूं इनफैक्ट
करता हूं इनफैक्ट करने के बाद आपको क्या
देखने को मिला था जब मैंने आपको ओपन किया
ये रहा ये रहा तो आपको भी यहां भी कुछ ना
कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलेगी देखो जब
यहां पे इनफॉरमेशन देख रहे हो क्या मिलेगी
[संगीत]
इनफॉरमेशन
मिलेगा कहां मिलेगा एयरपोर्ट
[संगीत]
देखने को मिल रहा है
यह देखो यहां पर इनफॉरमेशन है
अगर मैं आपको जूम करता हूं
यहां पर
मिल रहा है की यहां से एक्सपोर्ट होगा इधर
से इनफॉरमेशन यहां भी इसके अंदर छुपी हुई
है तो दो तरीके से आपको कंफर्म कर का रहे
हो ऊपर से क्या की मैंने क्या किया यूजर
नाम हो सकता है तो सबसे पहले क्वेश्चन
हमारा क्या था सबसे पहले एक क्वेश्चन था
व्हाट यूजर अटैकर को बाय कौन सा यूजरनेम
हो सकता है तो हमारे लिए कौन सा यूजर नाम
होता है ये रहा इसका पूरा 100 एंजेल ये
वाला क्या हो सकता है यूजरनेम हमारे लिए
हो सकता था हम क्या करते हैं कॉपी करते
हैं और डेफिनेटली हमारे लिए यूजरनेम
मिलेगा तो इसको क्या कर दूंगा पेस्ट कर
देता हूं पेस्ट उसके बाद में सबमिट कर
देता हूं
उसके बाद हमारे पास जैसे ही मैंने गोल
सर्च किया जैसे ही मैंने गूगल सर्च किया
है यहां पर आपको देखने को क्या मिल रहा है
तो यहां पर
देखने को मिलता है
देखने को मिल रहा है तो ट्विटर पेज में
मैंने ओपन गया उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
यह तो आर्टिकल है उसके राइटर उसके बाद
क्या है की तो एंजेल ओनर फ्री गेम्स ओ आई
डोंट नो की ये होगा उसका इंस्टाग्राम पेज
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है ये रहा ये साड़ी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिल गई अब मैं ये
कहूं ओपन करता हूं ये देखा ये इनका डाटा
पेज है पेज में देखो आप आपको क्या करना है
ना अभी जितना भी आपने शिखा है जो भी कुछ
आपने सिखाया वो सब कुछ यहां अप्लाई कर
सकते हो की मैं जस्ट क्या करना मैं लैंप
सॉल्व करके दिखा रहा हूं आपको लेकिन आपको
लेफ्ट सॉल्व करने की जरूर नहीं है आपको
क्या करना है आप लैपटॉप करने की बजे आपको
क्या करना है की आप जाइए और जो जो आपने
सिखाया है फेसबुक पे सेंड एन ट्विटर या जो
भी आपने सिखाया आपको क्या करना है इस पे
अप्लाई कर देना अभी क्या है की मैक्स
जितनी इनफॉरमेशन नहीं कर सकता हूं गदर कर
सकते हो क्योंकि इसमें आपको प्रैक्टिस
करने को मिलेगी क्योंकि आपके पास टारगेट्स
हैं और आसानी से प्रैक्टिस करते हो ये कोई
इलीगल नहीं है क्योंकि ये साड़ी वैल्युएबल
मशीन और यहां पर क्या है अच्छी खासी
इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी इससे आपको
आइडिया मिलेगी इनफॉरमेशन
कैसे होती है टारगेट के बड़े में तो आप
जाइए और ऐसे इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते
हैं तभी देखिए यहां पर
फाइल दे आपको देखने को मिल रही है
सीपीयू माइंस
आपको देखने को मिलती है तो फर्स्ट
क्वेश्चन हमारा हो गया सेकंड क्वेश्चन में
हमसे ये क्या जानना चाहता है सेकंड
क्वेश्चन में हमसे जानना चाहता है
फेडरल मिस्टेक इन देवर ऑपरेशनल सिक्योरिटी
दे सिम तू हैव रूसे डर यूजर नाम एक्रॉस
अदर सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म
लेकिन यह किसके साथ हो सकता है
वह किसी चीज के लिए एक्सपर्ट था उसने
एक्सपर्टीज को उसे किया और अब उसे यह नहीं
पता था की अपने आप को बजाना क्या है उसने
क्या गलती की उसने गलती यह की किसी पे
साइबर अटैक किया उसके बाद उसने क्या कर
दिया ए जो उसका यूजरनेम कहां से एक्सपोज
हो गया आपको मेटा डेट है जो आपको इमेज
मिली इमेज
आपको देखने को मिल गया और उसने क्या किया
दूसरी गलती क्या की उसे यूजर नाम को हर एक
सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफॉर्म पर उसने उसे किया
हुआ है तो उससे क्या कर दिया की अब और भी
ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं करने में हमें
हेल्प मिल रही है क्योंकि अगर वो एक कम
करता है अगर वो जस्ट एक यूनिक नाम यूजर
नाम उसे रखना ठीक है अगर वो हमें यूनिक
यूजर नाम देखने को मिलता है की इसके ऊपर
इमेज इमेज के अंदर जो मटर डाटा के अंदर तो
उसके बेसिस पे हम इनफॉरमेशन देते हैं
क्रैक नहीं कर पाते क्योंकि हमारे पास
यूजर नाम होता है इंडिया विदाउट यूजरनेम
वे कांत फाइंड एनीथिंग तो अब हमारे पास
क्या है यूजर नाम देखने को मिल गया अब ऊपर
से दूसरा क्या गलती क्या कर दी इन्होंने
अटैक कर दिया उसके बाद क्या आएगी सारे
सोशल मीडिया कोई यूजर नाम है तो इससे कम
हमारा और भी आसन हो गया अब इंस्ट्रक्शन
में क्या बोल रहा है की मोस्ट डिजिटल
प्लेटफॉर्म्स मेकिंग आईटी इसे इजी तू
फाइंड अदर अकाउंट्स ओंड बाय डी से परसों
व्हेन डी यूजर नाम इसे यूनिक दिस कैन बी
स्पेशली हेल्पफुल ऑन डी प्लेटफॉर्म सच आगे
ऑन जब हंटिंग साइट वेयर ए यूजर इस मोर
लाइक्ली तू प्रोवाइड रियल इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट
डेम सेल्स अच्छा देवर फूल नाम पर लोकेशन
इनफॉरमेशन
अकाउंट एक्जिस्ट और नोट तो इन ऑर्डर
ट्रांसफर
तू एक्सपेंड डी ओपन सोर्स इन्वेस्टिगेशन
ऑन तू अदर परफॉर्मेंस इन ऑर्डर तू गदर
एडिशनल आईडेंटिफाइंग इनफॉरमेशन ऑन डी अटैक
दिया है तो अभी हमें क्या फाइंड आउट करना
है की व्हाट इसे डी ईमेल फूल ईमेल एड्रेस
यूज्ड बाय डी अटैकर टाइटन क्वेश्चन व्हाट
इसे डी अटैक्स फूल रियल नाम अब हमारे पास
क्या है की वो नाम हमें कंफर्म लेक और
उसका रियल नाम है क्या है दूसरा हमें उसकी
ईमेल एड्रेस को फाइंड आउट करना है तो
हमारे पास चलो हमारे पास क्या है एक ही
इनफॉरमेशन है अभी ये हमारे पास डाटा है
हमारे पास एक ट्विटर है ट्विटर पे हम जाते
हैं ट्विटर पर सर्च करने की कोशिश करते
हैं इनफॉरमेशन करने की कोशिश करते हैं
देखो
अब हमें नहीं पता की ओरिजिनल फोटो है यह
डुप्लीकेट फोटो अब हमें इसी को क्या है ये
ओरिजिनल भी मां सकते हैं या अभी तक जब तक
हम छोटी नहीं है तब तक हम इसको नहीं
मानेंगे क्योंकि अगर आता है तो साइबर वाला
बांदा है तो डेफिनेटली वो क्या की पल्स या
ये फेक प्रोफाइल भी हो शक्ति है दूसरा
क्या है की इन्होंने यहां पर ए आई के आई
को ठीक है इसका
अकाउंट नाम उसे किया लेकिन देखो यहां आपको
जो आपको देखने को मिल रहा है जो इसका
यूजर नाम देखने को मिल रहा है अकाउंट यूजर
नाम देखो
@ उसका पूरा लो आगे हो ये इसका यूजर नाम
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है अब देखो टारगेट
आपके पास है मैं कम करता हूं यार आपके पास
काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
आपको देखने को मिली अब देखो आपके पास एक
तो यूजर नाम मिल रहा है
[संगीत]
तो एक तो ये क्या है आपको ये जो नाम देखने
को मिल गया ये जो नाम
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है ये ट्विटर के
ऊपर मिला है ये मिला हमें ट्विटर के ऊपर
ट्विटर के ऊपर मिला अभी देखो अब आपको
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलेगी तो यह रहा
21 यही इनफॉरमेशन है यहां पर आपको वन
फॉलोइंग है
इसको हम ओपन करके देख सकते हैं
आपको पता है कैसे इनफॉरमेशन के ऊपर या
आपको अच्छी तरह आप जानते हो वन फॉलो मी अब
ये देखो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट प्रून मिशन तू
एंपावर एवरी परसों और एवरी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
ऑन डी प्लेनेट तू अचीव मोर सपोर्ट देखो
मैं आपको कुछ इनफॉरमेशन नहीं है फॉलो रिंग
चलो हम वापस बैक तू इनके प्रोफाइल में
चलते हैं यूजर नाम मिल गया अभी यहां पर
क्या है इनके ट्वीट देखते हैं देखो नो मोर
पर गेटिंग मी अप मतलब एक्स पॉइंट वन आई
गेट न्यू फोंस ओके नो मोर गेटिंग मी
एक्सरसाइज
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलते हैं क्योंकि
यहां पर कुछ शेर किया हुआ रिजल्ट पर ये
रेगुलर वी-फी और पासवर्ड ओके
अबाउट समवन एल्स फाइंडिंग डेम ऑन डी डार्क
वेब
फाइंडिंग दम सेल्स ऑन डी डार्क वेब आनेवन
हूं वांट डेम बिल बी तू डू एन रियल दीप सच
तू फाइंड वेयर आई पेस्टेड डेम ओके लक्स
लाइक मी लास्ट पेज गो रिमूव्ड व्हेन डी
वेबसाइट चेंज डोमैंस एडिंग ए न्यू वन तू
रिमेंबर
इसने क्या इन्होंने क्या बोला देखिए क्या
बोल रही है ओ को की पोस्ट है जनवरी 24 अभी
अक्टूबर 2002 में इन्होंने क्या बोला है
लक्स लाइक मी लास्ट पेस्ट को रिमोट व्हेन
डी वेबसाइट चेंज डोमैंस एडिंग ए न्यू वन
तू रिमेंबर अब ये था पोस्ट ये पोस्ट अभी
देखो उसके बाद क्या है की सिली मी आई
फॉरगेट डी इंट्रोड्यूस माइसेल्फ है देवर
आई एम
@ अब ये देखो यहां पर कुछ अलग यूजरनेम
आपको देखने को मिलता है अब ये क्या है ये
देखो
अब यहां पर अलग प्रोफाइल
विदेश आदि बिगनर का चाइनीस ब्लॉसम सीजन
ओके उसके बाद क्लोज तू होम कांत वेट तू
फाइंड देखो यहां पे कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने
को मिल रही है की तो क्लोज तू होम कांत
वेट तू फाइनली बी बैंक ये भी कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन
है टेकिंग आउट सम लास्ट मिनट चेरी ब्लॉसम
बिफोर
हैडिंग होम ओके तो ये कुछ इनफॉरमेशन चलो
हम इसको ओपन करके रखते हैं अभी अभी तक
हमें क्वेश्चन से रिलेटेड आए नहीं बट यहां
पर कोई भी ईमेल एड्रेस हमें देखने को नहीं
मिलती है
ये देखो ये और ये कुछ है इन्होंने क्या
इसको
अलग ही है
अब यहां पर कुछ हमें ईमेल एड्रेस से
रिलेटेड देखने को मिलता है तीन पोस्ट 29
फॉलोअर्स है 46 है
आपको इसके बड़े में उसके लिए आपको लॉगिन
करना होगा और इसका ओसियन मैंने आपको अभी
तक बताया नहीं क्योंकि थोड़े दिन में
बताऊंगा अभी मैं तो इसके तीन पोस्ट करते
हैं ये तीन पोर्शन लोग इन करना है कोई बात
नहीं यहां पर मुझे वैसे भी अभी क्या है यह
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को नहीं मिलती अब मैं
क्या करता हूं मेरे पास क्या है ये मेरे
पास है ये रहा ये मेरा है
यहां पर आपको देखने को मिलता है
तो गेट अप में अब देखते हैं हम इसको ओपन
न्यू तब ओपन न्यू तब नेक्स्ट ये क्या है
डीटीएच यह क्या है चलो इसको भी देखते हैं
इसमें क्या-क्या देखने को मिल रहा है
टीजीपी देखते हैं टीजीपी की बीजेपी आप
लोगों को पता है क्या होता है गप की उसे
होती है इन जब भी आप क्या करते हो की आपका
ईमेल का डिस्क्रिप्शन करते हो या
सॉफ्टवेयर के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन करते हो
तो आप क्या करते हो गप का उसे करते हैं
जिसको हम बोलते हैं न्यू प्राइवेसी गार्डन
इन के लिए हम उसे करते हैं
चलो ओके हमने क्या किया उसके बाद बिटकॉइन
एक्चुअली
हम एक कम करते हैं हमने क्या-क्या ओपन
किया
कुछ देखने को मिल रहा है
हेलो वर्ल्ड
पब्लिक ओके छोटा सा प्रोग्राम है बट नथिंग
मोर मशीन इंपॉर्टेंट इनफॉरमेशन चलो हम
इसको क्या करते हैं बैक करते हैं
टेस्ट में को देखने को मिल रहा है इंपोर्ट
जावा है यहां पर कुछ ऐसे कुछ है जो हमारे
लिए इनफॉरमेशन है तो मुझे यहां भी कुछ
देखने को नहीं मिलन है चलो हम बैक मतलब
स्पेस में हमें कुछ नहीं है नेक्स्ट चलते
हैं हम ये रहा
आपका क्या देखने को मिल रहा है यहां पर
क्या माइंस स्क्रिप्ट करके कुछ लिखा हुआ
हो की हम इस पर क्लिक करते हैं मैं आपको
देखने में कुछ मिल रहा है यहां आपको देख
रहा है की पेटीएम
वर्कर आईडी पासवर्ड
@ मीनिंगफुल पोर्ट कुछ ऐसा कुछ है आपको
देखने को मिल रहा है की कुछ है ये तो एक
कम करते हैं बट हमें अभी इस पे ईमेल से
रिलेटेड कुछ देखने को मिल लेते हैं चलो हम
इसको ओपन कर देते हैं देखते हैं की कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन
बीजेपी के अंदर आपको क्या पब्लिक की देखने
को मिलती है और यहां पर की देखने को मिलते
हैं पब्लिक की अभी देखो पब्लिक ही है और
हो सकता है किसी चीज की पब्लिक की हो
शक्ति है या तो पब्लिक की है आपकी इसमें
इसमें कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको हायड की भी मिल
जाए या आपको ऐसा हो सकता है की किसी
एक्सेस के लिए पब्लिक की देखने को मिल जाए
कुछ भी पब्लिक की देखने को मिल शक्ति है
अब यहां पर क्या किया स के लिए नहीं है
क्योंकि ये गप है तो ईमेल से रिलेटेड कोई
इंक्रिप्शन हो सकता है कुछ भी हो सकता है
हम एक कम करते हैं इसको क्लिक करते रहोगे
रो पे क्लिक किया हमने और इसको
हम क्या करते हैं कॉपी करते हैं कॉपी किया
मैंने इसको अरे यार चलो चलो
कॉपी करते हैं कॉपी करने के बाद इसको हम
क्या करते हैं अपने फाइल के अंदर से
करेंगे
पब्लिक
पब्लिक की पब्लिक
कर दिया
कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं
यस यस में से कर दिया
पब्लिक की अब हमारे पास क्या है की एक
कमांड होती है कमांड का नाम होता है जी
कमांड का नाम होता है जीपी
उसके बाद हिफिन हिफिन क्या कर डॉग इंपोर्ट
कर सकते हो
मैंने उसके पब्लिक की
पब
इंपोर्ट पब्लिक की मैंने कर दिया यहां पर
देखने को यहां पर कुछ है इनफॉरमेशन आपको
देखनेकोम यहां पर ईमेल आईडी उसकी देखने को
मिलेगी जो हमें क्या चाहिए ईमेल आईडी
चाहिए थी ऑफिस सिलेक्शन किया अब आवाज
क्वेश्चन था उसका क्या असर है देखो
व्हाट इसे डी फूल ईमेल एड्रेस तो ईमेल
एड्रेस या उसे की गई है मैंने सबमिट कर
दिया नेक्स्ट व्हाट इसे डी अटैक का फूल
रियल नाम फूल रियल नाम आपको पता है
क्योंकि हमें रियल नाम यही मिला है अटैकर
का रियल नाम
ये हो सकता है हम क्या करते हैं इसको
सबमिट करते हैं
यह देखने को मिलेगा
फूल रियल नाम और पेस्ट इसका फूल
इतने क्वेश्चन हमने सॉल्व कर दिया है
क्योंकि यहां तक हमने क्या करते हैं
क्वेश्चंस सॉल्व कर दिए हैं नेक्स्ट बढ़ते
हैं
साइबर क्रिमिनल इस अवेयर डेट की वे आर ऑन
तू डेम तो इन्वेस्टिंग इन्वेस्ट
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग इन देवर गेटअप अकाउंट
यह प्रोवाइड देखिए यहां पर आपको देखने को
मिल रहा है देखो
साइबर क्रिमिनल है वह अवेयर हो गया है की
हम उसके पीछे हैं तो आगे भी वन
इन्वेस्टिगेशन तू डर गेट है अकाउंट जब हम
क्या कर रहे थे गेट ऑफ अकाउंट पर
इन्वेस्टिगेशन कर देता हूं वहां पर हमने
कुछ इंडिकेटर देखें थे कुछ वहां पर हमने
ऑब्जर्व किया था कुछ अकाउंट ओनर से
रिलेटेड तो मैंने आपको दिखाए था जहां पर
कुछ एडिटिंग और डीलिटिंग से रिलेटेड आपको
इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही होगी तो ऐसा
कुछ है यहां पर तो एक्चुअल में हमें क्या
फाइंड आउट करना है तो पढ़िए देखो आप आराम
से पढ़िए टेक योर टाइम ऑन सम प्लेटफॉर्म
इंसर्टियों और अवेलेबल दिस ऑडिट हिस्ट्री
एलोज इन्वेस्टिगेटर तू लॉकेट इनफॉरमेशन था
वास ओंस इंक्लूड पॉसिबली बाय मिस्टेक और
ओवर साइड और दें रिमोट बाय डी यूजर्स
ऑफ इन्वेस्टिगेशन इन ऑर्डर तू ट्रांसफर
यू बिल नीड तू परफॉर्म ए डिपर दिव इन डी
हैकर्स गेट अप अकाउंट पर अन्य एडिशनल
इनफॉरमेशन था मे हैव बिन अल्टर्ड और रिमोट
यू कैन यूटिलाइज दिस इनफॉरमेशन तू ड्रेस
सम ऑफ डी अटैक्स कैप्टन देखो ऐसे इंग्लिश
लिखिए
हम क्या कर रहे हैं
की व्हाट इसे डी ई
व्हाट इसे डी अटैकर्स वैलिड एड्रेस ओके
उसका जो वॉलेट का एड्रेस है उसके बड़े में
पता कर मांग रहा है उसके बाद क्वेश्चन है
व्हाट मीनिंग पुल डिड डी अटैक कर रिसीवड
पेमेंट फ्रॉम ऑन जनवरी 23rd 2014
अब ये बोल रहा है की यहां पे पूरा
किप-खेंi मतलब क्या है की जब उसने कुछ
अटैक किया कुछ ना अपना लेने दें किसमे
किया है क्रिप्टो ई में किया है तो वो
इनफॉरमेशन हमें कैसे देखने को मिले देखो
आपको एक हिंट मिल गया होगा यहां पर
नाम की चीज देखने को मिली थी यहां पर
बिटकॉइन और
ट्स क्या होता है अगर मैं आपको
सर्च करके दिखा देता हूं ऐसे आपको
क्या होता है
प्राइस टुडे तो यह क्या है
रिलेटेड आपको इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती है
बीजेपी वाला हमारा कम हो गया ये हमारे पास
ओपन है ये हमारे पास ओपन है ये हमारे पास
ओपन है उसके बाद क्या थे बिटकॉइन बिटकॉइन
मैंने ओपन करने के लिए बोला था हमने कम
करते हैं बिटकॉइन वाले को भी एक न्यू पेज
में ओपन करते हैं हम यहां बिल्कुल
वाले को ओपन किया है ये रहा बिटकॉइन में
भी आपको देखने को मिल रहा है क्या यहां पर
ऐसा कोई इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रहा है
[संगीत]
देखो
आपको देखना है वैसे तो मैं कम करता हूं
अब यहां पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
कंट्रोल भी यहां पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिलेगा
करके दिखता हूं आपको अभी देखो देखने को
मिल रहा इनफॉरमेशन
इनफॉरमेशन
कंट्रोल
एड्रेस
व्हाट मीनिंग पोल अब एक क्या होता है की
हम कई बार आपकी जो वेबसाइट होती है
कहानी पर आपको क्या हो सकता है की कई बार
ये होता है की अगर आपके पास आईडी होती है
ना कोई भी ट्रांजैक्शन आईडी होती है
आप ट्रांजिशन देख सकते हो
हम ट्राई करना क्यों छोड़ेंगे हम क्या
करते हैं हम ओपन करते हैं वेबसाइट को कौन
सी वेबसाइट ओपन करते हैं हम ओपन करेंगे
[संगीत]
ईथर camp.in
नो यूजर वास फाउंड की दिस ईमेल ओके
[संगीत]
ईमेल और पासवर्ड ओके
फिर भी हम अगर
अंखियों के बाद
नो तो हम यह कम नहीं कर का रहे चलो
ओपन करो
ओके यह देखो यह अभी कम कर गया
देखो
[संगीत]
और ये रहा
है
लेकिन इसकी डेट हमें यहां पर देखने को
मिलेंगे
[संगीत]
ओपन ट्रांसफर
यह देखो यहां देखो
[संगीत]
फ्रॉम इस आईडी से आउट हुई है इतनी वैल्यू
और टोकन क्या है
और उसके बाद ट्रांसलेशन
व्हाट वास डी क्वेश्चन हमारा क्या है
अगर हम क्वेश्चन देखें
[संगीत]
ओके स्पेलिंग गलत है
यह नहीं हो शक्ति ओके
हां हां हां हां इनफॉरमेशन
विद यूजिंग
जो भी मैंने अभी तक करवाया है जितना भी
गांव से आउट तो नहीं है कुछ भी कीजिए ना
सब कुछ फाइंड आउट करना देखो जो कुछ मैं कर
रहा हूं वही चीज कुछ भी अवेलेबल मैंने उसे
नहीं किया सिर्फ वही इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर
रहा हूं इस के बेसिस पे इन क्वेश्चंस का
आंसर मैं आपको देने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
कुछ अलग तो कर नहीं
बर हो गया बताइए
बर हो गए क्यों
प्रिंस क्यों
बताइए जरा
बताना जरा यार
गैदरिंग इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट डेम आफ्टर देवर
देखो अभी क्या है की
अभी क्या है की साइबर क्रिमिनल अगर हो गया
की उसको पता चल गया की हम क्या कर रहे हैं
की उसके बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर
रहे हैं अटैक
दे उसे अपर तू उसे एन डिफरेंट यूजर नाम
दें
ओके देख लिया क्या बोल रहा है की
कितना अच्छा बनाया उन्होंने इनफॉरमेशन
जो ओरिजिनल नाम मिला हमें यहां से देखने
को मिल रहा है लेकिन अब क्या है की
इन्होंने बोल रहा है की जो आपका ट्रैक्टर
है उसको पता चल गया की आप इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग कर रहे हो उसके बाद में उसने क्या
कर दिया की जो ट्विटर का अकाउंट है उसका
क्या है उसने अलग यूजरनेम छोड़ है
ओबवियसली उसका अलग उसमें ट्विटर अकाउंट
विच दे यूज्ड अपर तू उसे डिफरेंस
सीनरी एचडी ओके
आई डोंट सी व्हाट यू आर डूइंग
बैक होम बाय ओके उन्होंने क्या किया की अब
अटैक करने के बाद इनको एक
कुछ मैसेज
चलो चलो चलो
अटैक
किस्मत सोचिए की मैं नहीं देख रहा हूं
अब देखो यहां सोने की इनफॉरमेशन
क्या है उसका ट्विटर अकाउंट है कहां पर है
ये रहा अकाउंट अब ये वो ट्विटर अकाउंट है
ट्विटर अकाउंट में बहुत कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रही होगी आपको
बहुत कुछ इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिल रही है
और मैंने क्या किया आपको जितना भी अभी तक
ट्विटर के बड़े में डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन आपको
बताई है तो अभी एक कम करेंगे
जितने भी लाइक है फॉलोइंग से आपको देखने
को मिल रही है जी तरीके से मैंने जो
ट्विटर का 3 दिन के अंदर टाइम लेकिन
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करवाया आप लोगों का
नो इट्स टाइम तू यू अब आप लोगों का समय है
यह आप लोग क्या करना है आप लोगों को यह
साड़ी पोस्ट पढ़नी है ट्वीट्स पढ़नी है
अरे ट्वीट्स को समझना है इस ट्वीट में
क्या बोल रहा है और हर एक को क्या करना है
आपको अभी आपका कम है वो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग
करना जो मुझे चाहिए जो आने वाले क्वेश्चंस
का आंसर आपको प्रोवाइड करेंगे तो यह आपका
टास्क है पूरा ट्विटर पे जो भी इनफॉरमेशन
जो भी इमेज आपको देखने को मिल रही है ग जो
चाहे इमेज व्यूवर्स उसे करो ट्विटर की
एडवांस टेक्निक उसे करो अब आप लोगों मैंने
काफी कुछ बताया ही आप लोग टास्क है एक
अच्छी रिपोर्ट बन्नी चाहिए नेक्स्ट क्लास
से पहले और उन क्वेश्चंस के आंसर आपके पास
हनी चाहिए उन क्वेश्चंस के आंसर आपके पास
होने चाहिए अभी मुझे नहीं पता कैसे आएंगे
मैं करके जरूर दिखाऊंगा की वो क्वेश्चंस
के आंसर कैसे आएंगे
कमेंट क्षेत्र में नेक्स्ट मुझे क्या करना
है मुझे यहां चाहिए
है उसके बड़े में पता करना ही कहां की
क्या जिओ लॉकेट करना है इसको जिओ लॉकेट
करना है इसको जिओ लॉकेट करना है अब जो
जिसको आप जियो लॉकेट करता है उसको जिओ
लॉकेट करना है और जिस-जिस के बड़े में जो
इनफॉरमेशन निकाल का रहे हो जो भी कुछ
निकाला का रहे हो क्योंकि देखो यह आपके
सामने क्या है सब कुछ टारगेट पड़ा है और
वो भी क्या है बल्ले बाल टारगेट है भर-भर
के इनफॉरमेशन है अगर रियल लाइफ सिनेरियो
में अगर आप ऐसे किसी को टारगेट करोगे तो
इतनी इनफॉरमेशन ऐसे आपको देखने को कभी
नहीं मिलेगी
हो जाएगा सभी से जितने भी हैं आप
रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे हो
एक साल बाद भी देख रहे हो
परमानेंट चीज इसमें कोई चेंज नहीं होने
वाला है ऐसा कुछ नहीं है इसका पैटर्न चेंज
हो जाएगा हो सकता है ट्विटर अपडेट हो
जाएगा बट क्या है की जो आपकी ये टेक्निक्स
है लगभग टेक्निक्स वही रहेंगे तो बताइए
सभी लोग कर सकते हैं उनसे भी उम्मीद कर
सकता हूं की जो बाद में रिकॉर्डिंग
देखेंगे उनसे भी उम्मीद कर सकता की अगर वो
1 साल बाद भी हमारी रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे
हैं तो हमारे पेज पर जाएंगे उसको लाइक
कमेंट करके
हमें बताएंगे
बताइए यहां पर टोटल 11 लोग हैं
कितने लोग
ट्विटर अकाउंट करके ले जाएंगे बेस्ट और
अभियान
शॉर्ट आप वहां पर कमेंट नहीं कर सकते हो
बताइए
ओके दो लोगों ने बोला है की प्रिंस और हर
वे बिल डू आईटी अदर दें
इसका दो ही मतलब
वॅटीवर योर डाउट इन डी प्रीवियस लास्ट
प्लेस या एवं टुडे क्लास
ओनली थ्री पीपल्स अरे वॉलिंटियर तू गिव
आंसर कंप्लीट डी टास्क प्रिंस
इन तीन लोगों के अलावा कोई ऐसा नहीं
इंटरेस्ट करता है की मुझे मैं कर पाऊंगा
यह टास्क
या
इसलिए नहीं कर का रहा
फिट टास्क 56 नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम पढ़ने
वाले हैं
की सीरीज हमारी काफी लंबी चलेगी और डोंट
वारी
आप लोगों को मुझे लगता नहीं की आप लोगों
वैसे तो कोई डाउट आएगा ही आएगा क्योंकि
मैंने काफी डीटेल्स में सबको सब लोगों को
बताया है एवं आपका सही कोई भी हो किसी भी
टाइप का इट्स मी गारंटी की आपको जो ओपन सो
सेंड कर लीजिए जो कंप्लीट कोर्स है जो
फ्री हो जो काफी पेड़ जिसके अमाउंट पे
पेमेंट लेते हैं लोग उसको मैं फ्री लिए
अवेलेबल करवा रहा हूं सभी के लिए
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन कर रहा हूं और काफी डिटेल
में डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन कर रहा हूं तो आने
वाले टाइम में कुछ और टॉपिक हैं जो भी
काफी फ्री अवेलेबल रहेंगे उससे पहले आपको
दिखाना जरूरी था की वो चीज कैसे कम में ए
रही है जैसे आप किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े
में ओपन सोशल कर पाओगे ऐसे किसी भी लाइट
टारगेट पर कर पाओगे
आपने देखा होगा की यहां पर ब्लास्ट स्टेप
बाय स्टेप बाय आपको गाइड किया गया बट क्या
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग आपको यह करनी थी
क्योंकि मुझे आइडिया है मैंने काफी टाइम
से आपको पढ़ा भी रहा हूं तो मुझे पता है
की कौन से इस टाइप कहां है कौन सी
इनफॉरमेशन सही है कौन सी गलत हो शक्ति है
तो इस वजह से मैं फास्ट फास्ट में
ट्रांसपोर्ट तक कर पाया बट ये आप लोग का
कम है की आप कितना इसमें कर पाओगे इतना आप
इंवॉल्व हो पाते हो कितना इसको
पार्टिसिपेट कर पाते हो क्योंकि ये एक
फ्री है कोई फीड लैब नहीं है आप ट्राई
हैंग में भी अकाउंट बनाई है इधर इसको जॉइन
कीजिए और सिंपली इसके तास परफॉर्म करना
स्टार्ट कर दीजिए
और आपको मजा भी आएगा और आपको क्या की जो
भी शिखा है उसको उसे भी कर पाओगे अभी तक
आप बोल रहे थे की सर आप लोगों ने माना
किया है की हम पेटीएम या फेसबुक जैसे
कंपनी में जो आप हमें लाइव में दिखा रहे
हो उसे पर आपको हमें इनफॉरमेशन के लिए आप
लोगों को माना किया है की एजुकेशन
कर सकते हो
एड्स तास नंबर 546 में करवाऊंगी नेक्स्ट
क्लास में उसके अलावा फिर हम ओपन सोर्स
इंटेलिजेंस का एक और बहुत ही बेहतरीन
खूबसूरत थोड़ी हार्ड लैब के तरफ जाएंगे
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगी काफी मजेदार रहेगी
उसके बाद फिर कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक
करेंगे उसके बाद हम सोचते हैं की सोर्स को
हैंड करेंगे सेशन जो पोर्ट है इसको हम और
करने की सोचेंगे डोंट वारी को अगर लंबा
चला है तो ₹900 जुड़े रहिए और सीखने
रहेंगे और काफी लोगों की जो रिटायरमेंट ए
रही है की हमें निकाल है की या डोंट वारी
आपको हर चीज मिलेगी
जो भी चीज मिलेगी इस तरीके से मिलेगी जो
आपको
उसको कभी भी पैसे दे देना पड़े
मैं समझना हूं की आप लोगों को कोई भी डाउट
नहीं है तो मैं क्या करता हूं